At the time of making this video December, 2016,
it is probably a unique time for the periodic table in any of
your lifetimes, because the name of four different elements,
[inaudible] Muskogee, Liam, Tennessee Inn,
and a goodness son have all been announced simultaneously.
And it is extremely unlikely that this will happen again,
four elements at once for a very long time, if ever now,
Oh,
Gunnison element 118 is special for a number of different reasons.
The first thing which makes it very special is that it is the last
element on the mental layer form of the periodic table.
It completes a row.
The second point is that it is only the second element that has been named
after living scientists, the [inaudible].
And the third point is that it is a noble
gas.
And so we'll have particularly interesting properties and fourthly.
And the thing which I find most interesting is that there was a
case of scientific fraud or at least scientific
irregularity earlier on when a lab claimed to have discovered this
element and then had to retract that is say they were wrong.
So this element of Gudnason has been named in
honor of the very famous nuclear chemist or perhaps
physicist in Russia. You're, it's a lack of it.
So lack of which means son of Solak, again,
this young he's a pioneer and very
long time researcher in Dubliner the research
center to the North of Moscow.
The only other element that was named after living scientists with CBO Gilliam
named after Glenn Seaborg,
who was the discovery of plutonium and several other elements,
there is a slight difference because Gunnison does not type quite
the whole of agonist aliens surname in it.
But I think this is a trivial difference and it is
often been said that having an element named off two is much
better than winning a Nobel prize because Nobel prize winners get forgotten
pretty quickly.
Whereas your name is on the wall of nearly every school room in the
world. Well, at least every science lab in the world.
So it's a terrific Memorial. There's a bit of argument,
whether Einstein was told on his death bed,
that an element was going to be named after him,
but the formal naming was after his death and any way he didn't
discover or contribute to the discovery of the elements.
So I don't think that counts, I have not yet met your it's a luck of it,
but I hope that we will meet in 2017. And if we do,
there will be plenty of videos to market.
I think it's a terrific name and I fully support it.
It is interesting because the name ends in on O N,
which is the ending that is used for the names of all the noble
gases except helium, which does end with IUL.
The interesting thing is that as these gases get heavier,
they are going to be much less volatile.
That is they are going to be harder if you'd like for them to take off,
like it's harder for jumbo jet to take off than for a glider. If anything,
the evidence for element 118 is more secure than for
most other elements in this region of the periodic table.
And there is a reason why people want to be absolutely sure,
because in the late 1990s,
there was a claim from America that element
118 had been synthesized.
You have to understand that the output from an experiment,
it's huge quantities of data from a detector stored in a computer.
And then you have data analysis programs that look for the
results of decades, of these different elements and all being well,
you might discover one or two or three decades, but not very many.
What appears to have happened in this case is that one of the researchers about
that Gary and physicist called Nina appears to have in some way,
either change the date or change the algorithm.
So it appeared that element 118 had been discovered after two or three
years,
it was decided that the experiments could not be duplicated other labs,
trying to do it, and couldn't find any trace from their particular recipe.
And also even looking at the original data.
People couldn't reproduce the analysis.
And so the original paper was withdrawn.
I think this is an enormously important lesson to all of you who are
doing science.
You should enjoy the results you get and you should not
try and fiddle the results or massage the data to try and make them
better. Because first of all,
if you're found out it will destroy your reputation,
but most important of all the joy of doing science is to
understand nature, to understand how matter behaves.
And if you cheat, you don't understand anything.
So it removes all the joy and excitement of doing
science.
The other reason people have got so excited about elements,
119, a goodness on is that it completes the mental life
periodic table.
You have a nice complete row and it looks as if it's finished.
And several people already asked me, is there going to be any more element,
119 elements,
120 and quite conveniently.
My answer is on this Japanese tea town,
where you can say,
if you draw the periodic table,
like this is not actually finished at 118,
because 119 and 120 are there on the right
hand side. So we could,
even if we use the traditional Mendeleev style one,
we could just start a new couldn't work. Yes, of course we can start a new row.
The advantage of this format is that it shows us
that there's nothing special about 118 being the
last one. And it gives us encouragement to keep going.
You could of course say in the Mandalay format, well, you know, it's complete,
we're never going to be able to do it. Whereas if you look here,
you can see it's quite reasonable.
I very much hope that in the next year or so
that the first glimmers of a result for 119 or more,
probably 120, because if you look at the history of the periodic table,
the even elements seem to be discovered before the odd ones.
I think there is a real chance that we will keep going
and nobody will be more excited than I am. Well, perhaps you're,
it's a lot of [inaudible] maybe even more excited,
five years in the job. Can you imagine what that must be like? Yeah.
That's nothing because the longest serving foreign secretary of the Royal
society is that man behind us, very famous scientists.
This is Thomas Young and my great hero because he was such a
good foreign secretary. Now, professor,
clearly I don't have to introduce you to Keith because here's a little secret
view is.